somebody I'm thrilled to call a great
friend and he's the only one who I
believe is sheltering in place with all
the Emmy Awards right now and it was
great to see him his face and hear his
voice throughout the entirety of the
last dance because he was the studio
host for so many of those years of the
NBA on NBC and was also the voice of the
NBA Finals for Jordan's last dance and
we are thrilled to have him back here on
the Rich Eisen show Bob Costas how are
you Bob hi rich how you doing I'm doing
fine what do you think of the last dance
Bob I thought it was a masterpiece an
absolute masterpiece um I don't know
what the quibbles might be but I've
known Jason hair since he was a young
producer at HBO when I was there in the
early 2000s you could tell right then
even when he was just in his mid-20s
but he was going to be something special
and he and his team did a magnificent
job with this it's entertaining it's
compelling it has it's not strictly
journalistic but it has elements of
journalism it has elements of history
and I said to him last week I said it's
a mark actually of how impactful this is
that you're going to get the occasional
quibble it's like and I'm comparing it
out to the absolute gold standard it's
like any of Ken Burns documentaries
because they're so widely seen and
appreciative and appreciated rather and
because they're viewed as definitive
you're always going to get some people
with equivalent they do that that's
actually a tribute to how widely seen
and how and how widely appreciated it is
that everybody weighs in from every
direction and if you get a 95% thumbs-up
in this world you're doing great well I
give it 100% percent thumbs up but I
have 95 out of 100 observers I give 100
percent myself know exactly but I I will
raise my hand and say I'm I have a
quibble even though I'm as you know I'm
not a quitter
I just wanted some definitive closure or
recounting of the actual nuts and bolts
of the dismantling of this team as
opposed to Jerry Reinsdorf giving us
some word salad and
Jorden seeing it for the first time on
his iPad I I just wanted some form of
why when when everybody just saw what we
just saw wasn't there one last chance
was there one last run at it right and
Jordans saying that he would have was
that surprising to you having covered a
team for that last dance to hear Jordan
saying yeah I'd run it back one more
time if I could convince Scottie I guess
mildly surprising
we knew throughout that season that it
was overwhelmingly likely that this was
in fact the last dance and it wasn't
just in Game six a clinching game in
Salt Lake City
but at various times throughout the
season we alluded to it they played a
game seven in the Eastern Conference
Finals against the Pacers who gave them
a very tough time and actually the
Pacers led 19 to 7 early in Game seven
on Chicago's home floor so our entire
opening for that game was this might be
the last dance on their dance floor this
is where it could end right here so that
was a narrative thread that ran through
the entire season and I understand
Michaels competitiveness he has the
right to have any feeling he wants he'd
like to come back for seven to eight
whatever it was but I really think that
the legend of all this is enhanced both
the Bulls legend and Michael Jordan's
legend is enhanced by it ending the way
it did first of all even if they want
another title or even two more it's hard
to imagine a scenario any more dramatic
theatrical and classic than what
happened in Game six in Salt Lake City
plus when you get that element of what
might have been
that's sort of what might have been
thing is an element that runs through
great literature great sports stories it
adds texture to the story and then also
remember 1999 was a lock out season it
was a half season might not have felt as
fulsome as the first six and if you go
beyond that they run into Kobe and Shaq
the first of their three in a row
in 2000 so at some point no matter how
great they were and no matter how great
he was
the last image was going to be unless it
ended the way it did was going to be
Michael Jordan walking off the floor at
some point in defeat isn't this better
and I realized that he came back four
years later with the Wizards but that is
a complete footnote and the last image
in the public imagination is that last
shot in Salt Lake City Bob Costas here
on the Rich Eisen show and another part
about the the last dance that was
remarkable was the relitigate
of one would I guess say arguments or or
rivalries and interestingly enough the
year two broadcast partners on that
night for the last dance Doug Collins
Jordan's former coach replaced by Phil
Jackson and Isiah Thomas whose story and
the dream team and him not shaking hands
with Jordan Witt was was absolutely one
of the biggest stories to come out of
the last stance in the first several
episodes was there any awkwardness
between Jordan and your broadcast
partners at all during that Finals Bob
you know I said this last night with
Scott Van Pelt this has to be said on
behalf of Isiah Thomas we know all the
other aspects of it going back to the
late 80s and early 90s oh no need to
rehash all that now
but his fate would have it Isaiah's on
the broadcast team his first year at NBC
for that last dance season never once
and I heard every syllable he uttered on
the air never once did he give a
backhanded compliment to Michael Jordan
never once did he diminish him never
once was there ever any yeah but never
once in any way did he throw any shade
at Michael Jordan he unequivocally said
often Michael Jordan was the best player
he ever played against and the best
player he had ever seen and that wasn't
just on the air I spent a lot of time
with Zeke in production meetings out to
dinner taking walks around Indianapolis
during the conference finals whatever I
never once heard him make a resentful or
bitter or unfair comment about Michael
Jordan now obviously there's something
stirring within him some 30 years later
but he's still hurt by it but
being a professional even in his rookie
broadcasting season he was completely
fair and completely professional but
another part of your question rich I
don't remember seeing Isaiah chatting
Michael up yeah at any of those
practices or before any of those games
that that I don't recall same Bob Costas
here on the Rich Eisen show so Bob
obviously and we'll get to baseball
before we say goodbye shortly but we you
cover that sport still do with MLB
Network spent many years on the NFL beat
with NBC the Olympics
obviously the NBA where does Jordan rank
in terms of athletes that you have
witnessed interviewed mentioned talked
to in terms of greatness and I know that
that is something that is defined
objectively or subjectively however you
want to put it where does Michael rank
for you Bob you know having heard this
having heard this question debated so
many times and having had it put to me
now so many times here's what I settled
upon I can't put anybody ahead of them I
know you can make a good case for others
you can make just as good a case and
maybe slightly better for Michael Jordan
so if forced to choose among team sport
athletes I've seen taken into account
all the aspects of it Championships won
individual honors presents impact on the
game all those things if I was forced to
pick I pick Michael Jordan but I have
respect for the other for the other
names that make their way into the
argument I wasn't an adult but I saw
Willie Mays play a lot of baseball I do
imagine a greater all-round baseball
player than Willie Mays hard to imagine
anybody being more of a master of their
sports and Wayne Gretzky was in a hockey
rink when Tiger Woods was as a golfer
during that several years when he was
absolutely in his prime so I'm not
sliding anybody else Jim Brown like
Jordan left at the peak but you didn't
have the same kind of coverage and
marketing and everything else yes I can
I'm not slide
anybody else I'm just saying that it
isn't just the popularity and the
attention and the marketing that make
Michael Jordan at the peak of that
argument or at least tied for first it's
his actual qualities and accomplishments
as an athlete even if it happened in a
vacuum so Bob before I let you go I've
got a couple minutes left before as they
say in the business the heart out at the
end of the hour the the world of
baseball is up in the air a lot of chess
pieces up in the air and we're not none
of us are epidemiologists or public
health experts but what do you think the
chances of a 20/20 playing season for
baseball is what do you think the
chances are Bob I think the chance of
them starting around July 4th is good I
have no idea what kind of percentage to
put on the likelihood of them getting
from point A all the way to the end
which would be a world series sometime
in November they've got the negotiation
hurdle to clear with the Players
Association and all the issues there but
I think that's actually the second most
difficult the most difficult by far are
all the health and safety issues they
put out the 67 page document that seems
to be very carefully considered it seems
they've taken into account almost every
possible eventualities and they're
taking it very seriously but there's so
many things potentially that could go
wrong so many potential pitfalls fingers
crossed I hope they can do it I hope in
some sense I can broadcast some games
but it's a tightrope walk to get from
July through to November because we're
all familiar with all the things that
might go amiss but you think that
there's gonna go they'll give it a whirl
essentially yeah I'd say well I think
they will and they maybe even have a
plan for if X number of players test
positive they've got fallback plans for
all of that but you know best laid plans
I hope I hope it works but these are
unprecedented at times we don't have any
model a and say this is model B we don't
know exactly where this is going to go I
don't blame them for trying I don't
blame it for having contingency plans
we'll just see how it plays out exactly
all right Bob
thanks for the time what's it like for
you to see yourself from back in the day
on the last dance I know I look the same
I don't I saw it last night but oh wait
you know the only difference Rich's hair
that's about it they'll have my hair a
little shorter than it was in 1979 this
WGN but you once with a fulsome head of
hair very handsome fellow is also a
strikingly good-looking bald man so you
say doesn't matter the vintage is
essentially what you're saying you know
I know I mean we got a kick out of the
WGN shot 1979 but in watching the more
relatively recent - stuff from the 90s
yes during all those fools seasons I
didn't remember everything I had said
something that I remembered but other
times I was sitting there going I said
that yeah I guess I did it's weird right
that that's you don't run you don't
remember saying it it's just like it's a
different person it's kind of crazy
yeah Bob stay healthy stay well best to
Jill and we'll chat soon
thank you thank you thank you that's Bob
Costas that's Bob Costas hey you watched
all the way to the end thanks for that
watch more right here